my favorite food is pickles
i wonder why no one google just might be
on everything
hi i'm miami and today i'm doing the
wired auto complete
interview okay how mayam bialik
how old is mayam bialik myambiolic is
44. she was born in 1975.
how did mayambiala get into acting when
i was 11 years old
my parents typed a letter on a
typewriter to different kids agents with
a picture of me that my dad took in the
backyard and said
this kid looks like ben midler and
barbra streisand what do you think
and that's i picked an agent from the
ones who were interested based on that
weird letter and my weird face
my first audition was to play dj on a
little show called
full house and the note that the casting
agent gave to my manager was
she talks too fast it's true how tall is
mayam bialik
if i stand up straight i'm five four and
a half
but i don't stand up straight so i feel
like i'm about like four three
how do you pronounce mayan bialik uh my
name is hebrew
mime is water my last name is actually
supposed to be two syllables
but in english we say be alec is my
imbiotic
is mayambialic canadian no i was born in
san diego
and i do not hold canadian citizenship
is my ambiance left-handed
i am mixed-handed i was born a righty my
mother was a lefty my brother was a
lefty
i was in a significant car accident
eight years ago which
made me have to become much more
ambidextrous so
i actually do all sports lefty so yeah i
guess i'm mixed handed but mostly right
is my like vegetarian no i'm not i am
vegan vegetarians typically eat eggs or
dairy i do not eat any animal product or
any animal byproduct so i am vegan
is mine be like a genius i don't think
i'm a genius if you're talking about
like iq classifications i don't even
know what those are
so no is my umbilical in a geico
commercial
no i'm not that little lizard that's not
me what mayam bialik
what is my ambiance religion my
religious affiliation
is i am jewish person of the jewish
faith
what is myanbialik's new show glad you
asked jim parsons and i are producing a
show called
call me cat it's about a very unusual
woman who does not have it all
but is still happy what did my umbilic
study
i have an undergraduate degree in
neuroscience
a minor in hebrew and jewish studies and
i hold a doctorate from ucla
also in neuroscience in the field of
psychoneuro endocrinology
what languages does my umbilic speak if
i had to find a bathroom or a hospital
i could do that in english pretty sure i
could do that in spanish
i could do that in hebrew and i can
read and write yiddish which is the
language of eastern european jews
i can do some sign language i know the
alphabet and some basic signs
and i speak the language above is mayam
bialik
is my bial related to margaret hamilton
no just because we both have prominent
noses
i mean come on people is my ambiance
related to bette midler
i'm not related to bette midler but i
did play that midler's character
when i was in beaches when i was 12
years old but we're not related
we just look alike is mine be all like a
real scientist
i mean it depends on your definition of
real scientists i do hold a phd in
neuroscience from ucla
i don't currently live and and make my
living as a scientist but i guess i'm a
real scientist yes
is my ambialic in what a girl wants
first i thought that said
is mayan be all like what a girl wants
and i was gonna be like oh yeah she is
i don't know what what a girl once is
but i don't think i'm in it but there's
a song
what a girl wants what a girl name
right okay is miami alex single
i'm dating someone but technical
technique is still open i guess
my mbi are mayan bialik and kaylee cuoco
friends
well we worked together for nine years
and i went to her wedding and
celebrated things with her i would say
we're friends
are mindy ellick and jim parsons friends
yeah jim parsons and
i check in with each other in life we're
working together on
this new show that we're producing
together i've been to
life events and know his family and
yeah we're friends can my ambiance
really play the harp
i learned to play the harp for the big
bang theory i'm a piano player a bass
player and a trumpet player
i did learn to play the harp rudimentary
for the episode
where leonard and penny get married that
is not me playing the heart because they
wanted like a really elaborate fancy
thing and i do not play well enough for
that so i play well enough to like play
everybody hurts by rem are you afraid of
the dark mind bialik
that's creepy yes can mayam be alex sing
yes i can did mayan bialik uh oh
did i what did mine be i'll go to prom i
did not go to my own prom
i went to my close friend sebastian's
prom
in laramie wyoming his parents and my
parents have been friends since before
we were born
and we grew up hanging out together and
he invited me to his prom
and it was awesome did my ambiance win
an emmy thanks for rubbing it in
no i didn't i think i was nominated four
times but
five i don't remember because i never
won did my ambiance really sing in
beaches
no that's a grown-up woman singing this
is a really interesting
kind of hollywood folklore bette midler
chose the voice that she wanted for her
character to sing like i do not sing
like an adult i was 12 i sang like a 12
year old who could sing
but i am singing along with the track
is why it mostly looks like i'm singing
because i actually was when we filmed
that
yep but i can't sing and i've sang glory
love a lot in my life
did my umbilic play blossom yeah
you could have just googled blossom and
see never mind mayam bialik
why is my ambiance vegan because she
loves animals
i'm gonna talk about myself in the third
person my idea
i am vegan because i love animals and
the way that i show my love
is by not consuming animals or any
animal
byproducts i'm vegan because of the
economic impact
that's storing animals for their um
flesh and by-products creates and i'm
vegan because of the environmental
impact
of farming i'm also vegan because of the
health implications
yeah when did mayam bialik join big bang
i'm terrible with numbers of years but i
appeared in the season finale of season
three
and then was made a regular at the same
time that melissa roush was melissa
roush who played bernadette we were made
regulars in season
four i had an infant and a toddler and i
was
trying to get back into the business
because i needed health insurance this
is a true story i had never seen the big
bang theory and i was told to go on this
audition
and i did they said we need a female jim
parsons and i said who's that
and i googled him and i was like oh i
get this character i
know everyone liked this character i
went to grad school and i did my best
impression of him
and on my resume it says miscellaneous
phd neuroscience but that's not why i
got the job
you don't have to be a neuroscientist to
play one on tv was my ambiance on
macgyver
yes i was why did my umbilic leave lego
masters
i think they mean why didn't i get to
stay to judge i really wanted to
i had a work appointment for call me cat
which is the show that i'm producing and
starring in with jim parsons
i had already booked lego masters and i
really didn't want to back out because i
really wanted to do it so they made it
so that i could at least be there for as
much as i could before i had to go
to work that's why i left why my mba
like youtube
i know right why because i love talking
to people about things that
are hopefully interesting and important
and i love
finding people like me i do a lot on
mental health i do a lot
on my life behind the scenes and i think
it's a really interesting way to
communicate with an audience
so that's why i mind being like youtube
who were mayan bialik's parents
two very very strange people my father
passed away five years ago
he was a filmmaker and writer and a
photographer he made his living as an
english and drama teacher
and my mother was also a teacher my
parents were civil rights activists
and my mother started teaching in the
women's prison in harlem
my parents were documentary filmmakers
together my mom taught early education
my father was and my mother is very very
quirky
funny outrageous and they also always
wear matching outfits like for family
events like we're both wearing flat
we're both wearing white linen
adorable was my embiolic in roseanne no
i mean sarah gilbert was in roseanne
unless you think i'm roseanne
oh was my bialik punky brewster no
and to the millions of people who shout
this at me on the street
hey punky brewster i was not punky
brewster sole moon fry was punky booster
that was an afternoon kids show
blossom was a prime time television show
on nbc will be aired after fresh prince
of bel-air i was not an orphan who wore
like different color shoes i was just
like a quirky girl who was smart but
also
popular ish who was my ambiance married
to i was married to my ex-husband
his name is michael his name's still
michael
does mayan bialy uh oh does my bialk
have a child
i do and then i also have another one
they're
almost 12 and almost 15. they're both
boys i don't know why i made that sound
so weird does mine be alk have siblings
yes i do i have a brother who's four
years older than me
does mine be alex have an instagram yes
i do
it's miss mayam m-i-s-s-m-a-y-i-m
like do you miss mayam also someone else
stole
my name so that's why i'm miss mayam
does my ambiance have a tattoo
as a matter of fact i have two and
they're both in relatively hidden places
and no it's not a dolphin on my ankle
thank you so much for watching wired
thank you for all your questions thank
you for your curiosity about me i mean i
think i learned new things about me so
thank you